The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So today
is the first screening
of your rough cuts.
And the way this will work is
I will show one of the videos,
and we'll all watch it.
You guys can take notes
on it while you watch.
And after each
screening we will give
general high-level
feedback to the creator.
And that's what-- we'll just
go through the whole class
and do that for the first half.
Now for the second half,
there are a couple options
that we could proceed.
The first being
what I usually do
with Science Out Loud, which
is to basically do Google
Docs for detailed comments.
And this is really
useful because it's
sort of like a check
box when you're
going back through and looking
at feedback from another person
when you edit.
So this was for
George's farts video.
And I made some
notes about where
we should add some animations,
where we should add overlays.
So this is one option
that we could do.
Basically break you guys
up to where you will end up
commenting on at least
two people's videos,
and we would know who
you would be assigned to.
The other option is
that we could just
go ahead and pair you guys
up or group you guys up,
and instead of doing the
Google Docs feedback,
you can just talk to
each other one on one.
Do you people have
preferences on how we do this?
AUDIENCE: Google Docs.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Google Docs.
Anyone else?
All right.
So we'll do Google Docs.
And I will give you
the details on how
that's going to happen during
the second half of class.
Sounds good?
So, as it was for
the table reads--
remember that repetitive
comments are OK.
It's OK if you feel the
same sort of feedback
that another person
has already said
because it'll draw
attention to the creator
and what they need to work on.
Also remember that at the end
of the day this is your video,
so the feedback is for you to
take or leave-- hey, Nathan.
And this is probably going
to be the most valuable class
time the whole month because
this is where you're really
going to have concrete advice
on implementing the stuff
that we've talked about so far.
So really take this
as an opportunity
to give as constructive
and meaningful feedback as
possible.
All right?
Does anyone have
questions or comments
before we start watching?
No?
Are you excited?
OK.
AUDIENCE: We need popcorn.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I thought
about making pop-- but then I
thought that if people were
taking notes on their computers
and they had, like,
butter on their fingers.
We'll pop for another screening.
AUDIENCE: --later for a snack.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's fine.
Maybe we should close the big--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
I'll close the door.
Does anyone want to go first?
No?
Does that show up on screen
OK if I turn these lights off?
OK.
OK, well, then we will
just go down the line.
How about that?
So lucky you, Nathan.
Do you want to say
anything before we screen,
or do you want to just go
ahead and watch and then
talk about your process?
AUDIENCE: I'm
going to be honest,
and I made a pretty
bad mistake in putting
off filming until yesterday.
And so I only got to get in
the editing this morning.
And it really shows.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well,
let's see what you have.
And there is time, that's
what tomorrow's for.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't get
the animations to work.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
And do keep in mind that
all day tomorrow and all day
Thursday is open for you
to incorporate feedback.
After today's class
ends, we're not
meeting again until the
screening on Thursday at 6:30.
So as long as we get
videos in by, like-- 6:00
PM's the latest.
Hopefully you're not
working up until 6:00 PM.
You have the rest
of the day to work.
PROFESSOR: But if you need
our help, then e-mail us.
And we can meet up if you want.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yes.
We will be in the classroom
tomorrow and Thursday
if people need help.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Why does your-- why does
your fridge start to smell?
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: The
sound sounds good.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Why does your fridge
start to smell?
And where does that icky
black liquid come from?
Wouldn't life just be
easier if things didn't rot,
if things lasted forever?
Well, maybe, but probably not.
According to the USDA, the
average American household
wastes 25% of its food.
And a lot of restaurants
are even worse.
So if we didn't
have decomposition,
what would happen to
the food we throw away?
Food in landfills normally gets
dealt with by bacteria, fungi,
and protists that allow
the nutrients in food
to return to the soil and,
eventually, other living
things.
These decomposers also
break down other dead stuff,
like trees.
In fact, they're pretty much the
only thing that can eat wood.
So in a world without rot,
while your home may not
have to worry about
being eaten by termites,
who rely on protists
in their stomach,
pretty soon forests
and landfills
would be flooded with
a lot of dead stuff.
So how do we avoid this problem?
Well, basically, in your
fridge, on a forest floor,
in a dumpster, almost
anywhere, there
are fungi, bacteria, and
protists that live entirely
by eating dead stuff.
These dead things can
be more or less divided
into three categories.
Carbohydrates--
sugar and starches.
Lipids-- think fats.
And proteins, like meats.
All of these are
chemically different,
so they each get broken
down by different enzymes
in different ways before
being absorbed by decomposers.
For example, proteases
break down proteins
into amino acids, the
cells building blocks.
Lipids rely on lipases.
And carbohydrates on things
like amylase and cellulases.
So how does a perfectly
nice broccoli floret
start giving off this
foul black liquid?
Fruits and vegetables are
almost entirely made of water.
So on the most basic
level, you could
say their cells are like
extremely complex water
balloons.
The exterior-- a
cell wall-- is made
of cellulose, a complex
carbohydrate that
gets broken down by enzymes
into small sugars the cell can
get energy from.
When bacteria or fungi
uses cellulase to eat
the exterior of
a cell, it's like
if I were to pop the balloon.
That's the muck you
see in your fridge.
And that's how you get
that icky black liquid.
What about that stink?
For fruits and
vegetables a lot of time
the smell happens after the
icky black liquid forms.
Other bacteria that
weren't involved
in the initial
colonization move in
and start to stink
everything up.
Meat gets smelly when
lipases break down
fat in the meat into
glycerol and fatty acids--
two energy sources.
And fatty acids
are kind of gross.
And so while your food rotting
may smell absolutely terrible,
because of it the
environment's able to recycle
crucial nutrients it needs.
And, well, that's
why we have all this.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Are you kidding?
That was awesome.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
General feedback?
PROFESSOR: Well, I want
to hear what you think
before we give you feedback.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Like
what are the things
that you like
about what you did,
and what are the
things that you already
know you want to change or add?
AUDIENCE: The audio.
ELIZABETH CHOE: The audio.
AUDIENCE: The lack of animation.
The main things.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
What was the hardest
part about making this video?
AUDIENCE: Actually going
and doing the shooting.
I kind of put that off as
long as I really feasibly
could have because I really
didn't want to do it.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Was it as painful
as you thought it would
be once you started?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
Well, I will say that
the script is very, very
tight in this video.
And it has come a
very long way from
your initial brainstorming.
And if you come
to the screening,
you'll get to actually
see all the pictures.
So, just a plug to come to
the screening if you want to.
But the script is super tight.
And I know that you spent
a long time honing that,
and I think that
really paid off.
It's two thirty-three,
which is a great time.
So I think that as far
as the content goes
it's really strong, and
I can tell that you spent
a lot of time developing that.
Does anyone want to
add some more feedback?
I mean, I can talk
to-- yes, Yuliya.
AUDIENCE: I like
the transitions.
There weren't too
many of them, but it
was nice to see a change
of background and scene.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
And clean cuts.
No funky swirls, no fades.
It's nice.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, definitely.
I was going to say something
else, but I forgot.
ELIZABETH CHOE: That's OK.
We can come back
if you remember.
Anyone else?
Yes, Andrea.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I really
like the pacing of it.
It's a little rushed
in a couple of places,
but that's-- that happens.
But I like the
pacing in general.
And I also like the
water balloon example
and the different
camera angles, and I
thought it was just really
artistically very well done,
very well composed.
ELIZABETH CHOE: What was
so terrible about actually
shooting?
Was it being on camera?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And also, each
one took a lot of takes.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I will say-- because I
know that a lot of you
expressed sort of
concern and hesitation
about being on camera, and I
feel like a lot of this class
has been like actually no,
you're really great on camera.
The opening shot is delivered
really, really well.
And there are spots
where, like Andrea said,
you're rushing your
words a little bit.
And I'm sure you'll see it
when you go back through.
And whenever you guys do
your Google Doc comments,
point out spaces where
maybe his delivery changes.
It is a little inconsistent
between scenes,
but there are some
scenes where it
is delivered so
perfectly and so clearly,
and you seem really, really
comfortable on screen.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I will say-- did
you shoot it by yourself?
AUDIENCE: I did shoot it mostly
by myself, since I put it off.
AUDIENCE: Because I found that
it was a lot easier to have
someone shoot it than,
like, when we were doing
those first blogs and
stuff at the beginning,
I thought that was a lot
harder doing it by myself
than having someone there.
I felt less comfortable being
alone than with someone.
Which is kind of--
I thought it'd
be the other way around when
I first started the project.
Other than that, like,
how I think he used--
went to Star Market.
So representing a
local grocer too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
I agree.
I like the part where he
talked about the smell.
You know?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I like
the cut on the fridge.
AUDIENCE: The visual, yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: What
do you guys think
about the visuals in general?
Because it's always hard to
do a chemistry or biology
video because the
visualizations are always
somewhat impossible to do.
Yeah, Yuliya.
AUDIENCE: I think it
would be nice to show some
of the scientific vocabulary,
so we can see it and not
just hear it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, like
a label on top or something.
AUDIENCE: And then
for the backgrounds,
like, the plants backgrounds
worked really well
and, like, the
fridge and all that.
But there was a part
where there was just
a random penguin or random
pictures on the wall that
maybe could be overlaid
with animation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Like this shot.
I like that you have
the kitchen space
as sort of your home base.
Because your centered on
the question of why things
rot in your fridge,
and that's what
allows you to
explore decomposition
at greater length.
But this is doing that whole
thing that a lot of web videos
do, where you
center the subject.
And I was talking
to Chris [INAUDIBLE]
about why it's so common
that SciShow does it
and Vsauce does it.
And it sort of gives off an
air of it being not as formal.
But it's also a little
bit comical, too.
And I think that
if you just-- even
if you zoomed in just
a little bit and got
rid of, like, this
spray thing on the side
and the cooking
things on that side,
it might help with this one.
Also remember to tuck your mic
in under your shirt if you can.
Let's see.
But you were talking about
this penguin here, right?
Yeah, so this--
I mean, you could
play around with keeping
this footage, if you like,
and just zoom in a little bit.
See if you can digitally zoom
in on the editing software.
If the resolution
kind of goes kaput,
you may have to
re-film that part.
But again, I think
Yuliya is right in that
be careful about having
visual distractors
when you don't really
need them there.
I do agree with-- was it Andrea?
Who said something
about the pacing?
Yeah, I think the pacing of
your cuts are pretty good.
Like, nothing lasts a little
too long, nothing's too short.
If you have B-roll,
it might give you
a little bit of breathing
room in between shots
where you're talking really fast
and you have a lot of content.
But yeah, like
stuff like this-- I
don't remember what
you're talking about here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --while your home may not have
to worry about being eaten by--
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: Comical
note on that, I
filmed in front of
someone's house,
and they actually came
out and asked me to stop.
And so I kind of--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, no.
AUDIENCE: --gave up on
actually filming at home.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Filming
in front of a house.
I mean, is this
in your dorm room?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
AUDIENCE: That's what my backup
idea was, since it's my home.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, actually,
I think that it works fine.
And I would say for this one,
do a wider shot for this one
because it doesn't
quite establish
that you're in your own place.
Like, if you can see you
sitting on your actual bed,
that might help a
little bit more.
So again, it's not a matter
of using wide or close-up
shots for the sake of using
them on principle, but like what
the background actually reveals
and sets for the audience.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
can you go back a little bit?
Because there was--
I was wondering
what your vision was for this.
AUDIENCE: Right there.
Yes.
I'm still missing stock footage.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, so
this is like a placeholder
for the rough cut.
I figured that was the case.
AUDIENCE: --what you
were planning to do here.
I was like, I'm not sure
what I'm looking at.
OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
Oh, the dumpster shot.
Yeah, I wanted to say
something about this, too.
If this is something that
you decide to re-shoot,
I would also maybe scoot
back a little bit as well.
Because it's hard to tell
that it's really a dumpster
until you actually say it.
Where was this?
AUDIENCE: It's down
at the loading docks.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: I had a lot of
trouble with the dumpsters
I'd planned on going to.
By Walker is a bit
of a wind tunnel.
And the Stata Center, out
behind W20 was really noisy.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Which one's W20?
AUDIENCE: The student center.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, OK.
I mean, there is
an optimal dumps--
if you guys are ever in
need of an optimal dumpster
to fill up, let me tell you.
Right behind the MIT
Museum-- by D-Lab actually--
there are some prime
dumpster spots for shooting.
And that's where we shot
George's farts one, too.
So if you need to.
But in this one, I mean,
I think it's really
matter of the camera angle.
Did you shoot this on a tripod?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
Were you limited by how far you
could let your mic cable go?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
Yeah, maybe think about this one
as a potential one to re-shoot.
Because I think the visual
background makes a lot of sense
and is a really
good transition--
it's a really good change
from the kitchen setting.
So I would really love to see
that it's actually a dumpster.
AUDIENCE: And if
you are refilming--
only if you are refilming--
something that I noticed
is that when you're talking
you bounce a little.
So just-- like in
some of the film
when your up close we see that.
And it's just maybe
something that if you
can be aware of that
while you're filming.
It was just one moment, I can't
remember exactly where it was.
Where is it?
When you were talking, a
little towards the end.
And I noticed it a little
more, this sort of gentle
bounce while you talk.
That you don't do all the time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Maybe
we can find the--
AUDIENCE: I'll look at it
more carefully, because there
was a point where I was like--
AUDIENCE: I think it was
the end of [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Do you know
what I'm talking about?
OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Maybe we can
note that in the Google Docs,
whoever's commenting
on Nathan's.
And again, stuff like this,
I think it's great, but maybe
just like crop this
framing a little bit more
so it's a little
more rule of thirds.
Because the rule of thirds
works really well for this shot.
And [INAUDIBLE] pointed
out a really good tip.
When you do rule of
thirds, use the eyes
as sort of the point
instead of, like, your face.
Because there's just
a little too much room
on the top and right-hand
side of this framing.
How did you film the opening?
Like, were you by yourself?
Was it the first
thing that you filmed?
AUDIENCE: I was by myself, and
that was the-- no, it wasn't.
It was like second place I went.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
Because whatever
conditions you were
filming under for
this scene, I think
you should really
try to remember
what it was that you did.
Because this opening--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --start to smell?
And where does that icky
black liquid come from?
Wouldn't life just be
easier if things didn't rot?
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Like that question
is posed actually
quite naturally.
I think the tendency for a lot
of people when they're starting
would be to sort of overly
cheese that question up.
And that's sort of what
happened in early readings
that a lot of you guys did.
But this one just
sounds very natural,
like how you would actually
pose that question in real life.
So whatever conditions that you
were under filming this one,
really try to apply that
to whatever you re-shoot.
Were you there with him
for this one by chance?
Hmm.
Maybe it's an
energy level thing.
Like--
AUDIENCE: I think
it was I was inside.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You were
inside, so you weren't as
nervous about filming outside.
Yeah, actually, that does a
lot to people's deliveries.
But yeah, just something
to keep in mind.
Does anyone have final
thoughts before we
move on to the next video?
Do you know who we had paired
up to comment on Nathan's?
PROFESSOR: Andrea and Kenneth.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
So basically, for
the rough cut thing,
we will pair you
up with two people.
One of those people is
going to be the person who
helped film your video,
and the other person
is just someone completely new.
So Kenneth and Andrea are
commenting on Nathan's.
Andrea, do you want to say
anything about yours before we
screen?
AUDIENCE: There are lots
of placeholders for stuff,
like similar.
It's really boring.
ELIZABETH CHOE: We will
be the judge of that.
All right.
This is Andrea's.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Eating is one of the great
pleasures and necessities
of life.
And to enjoy everything
from energy bars to apples,
we rely on one
part of our bodies
to do an important
job-- our teeth.
Teeth are the hardest
substances in our bodies.
They're harder than
our bones, and they're
even harder than iron or steel.
While we chew our
teeth experience
forces of up to 225 pounds.
Hmm.
So why doesn't our
jaw just crumble
under all of those forces?
Between your tooth
and your jawbone,
there is a specialized
piece of tissue
called the periodontal
ligament, or PDL for short.
The PDL can easily
absorb the normal forces
that a tooth experiences when we
chew, say, an apple, cushioning
or protecting our
jawbone from our teeth.
And inside the PDL there
are all kinds of cells.
One type, called
mechanoreceptors,
sense forces of movement or
pressure applied to the tooth.
Teeth sound like they're
already perfectly designed.
But sometimes we really
need to force them
in a certain direction.
Like with braces.
As the braces slowly
force the teeth to move,
the PDL gets squeezed
in one direction
and stretched in the other,
kind of like a rubber band.
Here's where it
gets interesting.
To make room, the
mechanoreceptors
in the PDL trigger
cells called osteoclasts
that actually come
in and dissolve part
of your jaw to make extra room.
The mechanoreceptors also
trigger another kind of cell,
called an osteoblast,
which comes in
and builds up part
of the jawbone.
This allows the PDL to get back
into its regular cushioning
shape, thus holding the
tooth securely in position.
So if braces use osteoblasts
to physically reposition teeth
for cosmetic reasons,
what if we want
to use them to replace
things in our bodies?
Dental implants
replace teeth that
are damaged or missing to
restore chewing function.
And MIT engineers are
using the properties
of osteoblasts and osteoclasts
that are already in our bodies
to create a chemical
coding for these implants.
Just like in a
mouth with braces,
this coding helps
create natural bone
to help lock the
implant into place.
Your jaw isn't the
only place where
these osteoblasts
and osteoclasts are
altering your bone structure.
In fact, this bony
remodeling process
is happening throughout
your entire body.
And these implants aren't
just limited to teeth.
Doctors can replace knees,
hips, and even spinal disks.
Right now, these
implants are designed
to have the exact same
functionality as the parts
that they're replacing.
But in the future,
scientists may even
use implants to
improve our brains.
Just like with braces, we
could modify our bodies
to be more perfect.
Once we've tasted the
forbidden fruit of perfection,
will we still be human?
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
So, Andrea, why do you
think your video is boring?
AUDIENCE: It's really
dense with information.
It also doesn't have
very good settings in it,
except for the office.
And even in the
office, the lighting--
there was just nothing I
could do about the lighting.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think that one
of the quickest fixes that you
can do, and one that'll
make the biggest difference,
is that it's very slow moving.
And I think it's because you
are so conscious of fighting
the tendency that most people
have to deliver their lines too
quickly that you're talking a
lot slower than you usually do
in real life, in a way
that is clearly not you.
And you could actually
just play with speeding up
how fast the video plays.
We did that for one
of the people who
did Science Out Loud, actually.
The same thing happened to her.
As soon as the camera
started rolling,
she would talk just way
slower than she normally does,
and it just felt really
unnaturally paced.
And once we bumped up
the speed to, like, 115%,
it read a lot more normally
and flowed a lot better.
And I think in
general, look at where
you're cutting into new spaces.
I think that you erred
on the right side
for your rough cut, which
is to leave a little bit
too much room at the beginning
of each of your clips.
But when you go in,
really, you can shave off
like a good second, half a
second off of some of the clips
that you're cutting, too.
Instead of having a beat and
then your action starting,
just go straight into the
action already happening.
So I think that
happen a couple times.
[SKIPPING THROUGH VIDEO]
For this opening
shot I mean, just
start it like half a
beat before you say,
eating is one of life's
great necessities.
I think you take
these nice long pauses
in between some of your thoughts
to really let the viewer gather
or comprehend what you've said.
But some of the gaps
are just really long.
So you can either cut those
out and maybe cut to a close
up of you talking, or cut
to B-roll in those cases.
But I think that'll
help a lot with just
the sense of the movement
of the overall video.
Did anyone have other comments?
Yeah, Kenneth.
AUDIENCE: I remember in there
you were a little scared
to start filming.
But I thought you felt pretty
natural in front of us,
and it didn't feel you
were nervous or anything.
Apart from the slow speed,
I think actually you
look quite natural.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say that too.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
that one way to cut
that down is when you look at
a clip or you look at a song,
so you cut right
before the song.
And then it's like
a straight line.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Wait, sorry.
I didn't hear that.
AUDIENCE: Plus, when you put
the video as well as the sound.
ELIZABETH CHOE: The sound?
AUDIENCE: The sound wave.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, yeah.
The sound wave.
Yeah, the sound wave.
That's a very good tip.
AUDIENCE: Then I was thinking
that I like the transitions.
I find the transition
very meaningful,
and they help you
continue the story.
ELIZABETH CHOE: What
were you having planned
on this big section here?
Was it supposed to be
an animated section?
AUDIENCE: I've been
looking for images.
FEMALE IN VIDEO: This is
when we chew, say, an apple.
AUDIENCE: I think
one part that will
help that felt really
slow-- but maybe you
put in there for a visual
pause-- is the middle section
when you were talking
about putting on braces,
and you did the
whole sequence of you
like putting on gloves
like an orthodontist would.
And it's good for
comedic effect,
but it kind of interrupted
the video for me.
And I think this is an instance
of killing your darlings,
where I don't know how
long it took to film this.
AUDIENCE: So should cut out
everything in the office?
AUDIENCE: No, I like--
like when we all laughed,
that was a great reveal.
And I think you can
almost cut from this shot
to the one with
you with braces--
like when you say, with braces.
Because you don't even say
anything over this part.
It was just kind of silent.
AUDIENCE: I think
she could keep it
if she tightened it
to like one second.
We can get enough
out of you just
putting on-- starting
to put on the glove
and then transitioning
to the next one.
I think it's fun.
I think that I agree with
you that it's too long,
but I think you could
tighten it, really,
and it would still
get the impact.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Comedy is
really hard to pull off,
like George was saying
in the earlier workshop.
But a lot of comedy that works
in these types of videos,
and that you'll see in
SciShow or Veritasium
or pretty much any
popular YouTube channel,
is that they're very quick.
They're quick insertions of
someone making a face or sort
of an unexpected B-roll shot.
And I think that I
agree with Jaime.
And you can play
around with this.
Play around with taking
this part out completely,
play around with shortening it.
But it has a funnier effect
when it's a lot shorter,
because one, it doesn't
interrupt the flow of the video
as much.
And also just gives a
chance for the viewer
to be like, wait, what
just actually happened?
It keeps them on their
toes a little bit more.
AUDIENCE: For that, I
really like that part.
The only thing I
would suggest is
that at the end when you reveal
the braces to kind of show them
for half a second
longer so the viewers
can notice that it's braces.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think the
braces shot was actually
a little too short.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
like right here--
AUDIENCE: How did you do that?
The braces shot?
Did they just put pretend
braces on you for a minute?
ELIZABETH CHOE: It
was like a denture.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
this is an example
of shaving off some of
the beginnings of a clip.
That is exactly where it starts,
it's a good half a second.
Which doesn't seem
like much, but when
you're watching a video it seems
like an eternity-- half second
that you can just
take out completely.
AUDIENCE: So how close
to when the sound starts?
Should you do it right there?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I don't have a
best practice of do it like 0.2
seconds before it starts.
But I think that, in general,
having it as close to when
you start talking is best.
Because otherwise, it reads
a little bit newscastery.
Because you'll notice that
on a Dateline special,
the host will go, and
I'll start talking.
And that's what gives it the
newscastery feel, versus a lot
of YouTube channels
and SciShow, they just
go immediately as close to the
soundwave starting as possible.
AUDIENCE: Bring us
two frames back.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Two frames back?
AUDIENCE: I usually go like
two and three frames back.
And then if that
doesn't sound good,
then adjust it from there.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And who's
doing Google Docs for Andrea?
AUDIENCE: Nathan and Yuliya.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Nathan and Yuliya.
Any last comments for Andrea?
I do want to emphasize-- and
for the people who are just here
for today-- it is a
crazy amount of work
that they're doing in such
a small amount of time.
We basically spent the
first week not really
touching cameras whatsoever.
I mean, they were
doing assignments them,
but pre-production
takes up so much time.
So I think that the
scripts that you guys have
are really, really
tight and really good.
And I know that you're working
under limited time and very,
very limited resources.
Like you were saying,
you didn't have lights.
And that makes a huge difference
in what your final product
looks like, so
I'm really happy to see
that people can identify--
this is what I think it's
off about this video,
I think this is what
it would have improved.
That's the stuff that
really is important.
And I think the scripts, and
you guys really constructing
compelling narratives
around the topics
that you were talking about,
they've come such a long way
from the first day.
So I'm really happy to see that.
AUDIENCE: It's
ready, but I think
you have to refresh the page.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, OK.
This one?
All right.
Any words before we screen?
AUDIENCE: No disclaimers.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's good.
It's fine, I hope.
I just didn't like
how I cut it, but I
think it still is quite well.
I haven't finished
the animations,
but yeah, some of it's in.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Imagine holding
a party, and then
sending out invitations
after the party.
Wait a minute-- that
doesn't make any sense.
Are my friends are
going to be able to time
travel back just so
it's at my party?
In 2009, Stephen
Hawking actually
conducted such an experiment
to disprove time travel.
What exactly is time travel,
and how does it work?
It actually has a
lot to do with speed.
A lot of what we know about
time traveling actually
comes from Einstein's theory of
special and general relativity.
We are actually time
traveling right now, but not
in the manner that sci-fi
phi films have depicted them.
We are, in fact, time traveling
at a pace of one hour per hour.
In other words, every hour I
experience, the world around me
experiences a singular hour too.
Now, it may sound simple and
trivial, but stay with me.
This is where it
gets interesting.
Now, the lat part of Einstein's
theory of special relativity
is actually a phenomenon
known as time dilation.
Effectively, this means
that the faster you travel,
the slower time
passes around you.
It potentially
means that I could
travel at maybe more
than one hour per hour.
This phenomenon, however, is
only noticeable at really,
really high speeds-- speeds
near the speed of light.
This rocket here,
not even close.
Say I do a spaceship
now that travels
at 90% the speed of light.
And I have a pair newborn twins.
I bring one of them with me
on this journey for 10 years.
When I return, one of them
will have turned 23 years old
while the one with me will
have only turned 10 years old.
While we have experienced
10 years on a spaceship,
23 years have actually
passed on Earth.
This amount of time actually
increases exponentially
as you get closer to
the speed of light.
So we could potentially
travel forward in time.
But what about
backwards in time?
That's a whole other issue.
Now, remember our
previous graph.
The time that
passed on Earth was
asymptopic to the
speed of light.
Looks like we're seeing maybe
the secret to time travel
lies on the other
side of the line.
In other words, we may
have to travel faster
than the speed of light just to
be able to travel back in time.
Now, when you do travel
near the speed of light,
something called relativistic
mass comes into play.
In other words, as your speed
goes up, your mass increases.
As your mass increases,
you require more energy
to move the same object.
This might mean that you need
an infinite amount of energy
just to move an object
beyond the speed of light.
The more energy you put into
an object, the more likely
you are to increase
its mass rather than
to increase its speed.
Therefore, to get an object
past the speed of light,
quite impossible at
this point in time.
So why are we still so
obsessed with time travel?
Time travel does come with
its own set of problems.
Take for example
my party before.
If I were to send out my
invitations after the party,
my friends would have come
back in time to attend it.
And if they did come back
in time to attend it,
I wouldn't have sent
out my invitations.
And if I didn't send
out my invitations,
they wouldn't be at my party.
It doesn't make any sense at all
that they are both at my party
and not at my party.
This is what we call
the grandfather paradox.
It's one of three
time travel problems
that we currently have.
So it seems that we may
not be able to time travel
yet, based on what physics
tells us, at least.
For now, if you are
planning a party,
be sure to send out the invites.
Your friends can't
time travel yet.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right, any
comments from Kenneth first?
AUDIENCE: OK, I didn't know that
the warp stabilizer on YouTube
was like that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, you tried
the stabilizer on YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Because I new I had
to stabilize some of my footage,
and they were taking a
very long time on Premier.
So I just popped
it on to YouTube
and just let YouTube
stabilized it.
But I didn't know that
it did it very liberally.
So I realize a lot of my shots
got like this warpy effect,
and some of my text got
cut out, and what not.
But yeah, and I'm sorry that
the audio for this whole chunk
just kind of got
warped because I
had to use my other camera,
which I didn't want to.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, you used
your DSLR for the middle part,
right?
I mean it's a
trade-off, because it
looks way better than the
camcorders that we have.
But the camera
that he has doesn't
have an input for the mic.
Yeah, it's really hard
to understand that part.
Yeah, PJ?
AUDIENCE: With these
scenes, though,
we were talking about
doing this walking down.
It was just tough to
have a ten foot tether
to do some of these.
And I thought that came out
really good-- that video part.
AUDIENCE: Could you
try a voiceover?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was thinking
about putting that in.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's far away enough
where I don't think it matters.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, you could
try lip dubbing basically.
I have one pair
of wireless mics,
if you do want to
try shooting it.
I mean, it may be
a little too much
to throw in at the
last minute, because I
do agree that this part is--
[SKIPPING THROUGH VIDEO]
It's hard, but I
mean, I also think
that having that
wide of an angle
is important in that shot.
So I understand using
the mic was sort
of not really an option there.
But I do think that
voiceover is a good option.
And especially this part.
It's a long walk and talk, and--
MALE IN VIDEO: --example,
my party before.
If I were to send
out my message--
ELIZABETH CHOE: And the audio
is so distractingly unclear,
and this is such a
crucial sort of inherently
hard to understand
portion anyway,
that I think that it's really
important to have clear audio.
And I don't know if you can just
shoot B-roll to do voiceover
for this.
Because it's a little-- the
setting and what you're saying
don't necessarily match
up to me right away.
But I also like the
feel that you were going
for with this walk and talk.
I can tell that you were drawing
a lot of Veritasium influences
with the beginning, and you
did the whole Michael Stevens
Vsauce head up, which
I think are fun.
Because you're taking
something that is typically
a very robust science topic and
sort of presenting it in a very
casual, like, I'm
just your friend
talking about time travel
type of way that makes
it a lot less intimidating.
Which I think is really nice.
It's a nice feel for the video.
Any comments from anyone else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's sounded really
well in its complete form.
Even though-- like
the script, there
was a lot of technical detail.
It didn't read like that at all.
The only part here was that when
you were walking and describing
the grandfather paradox, I
know we also shot the party.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
thinking of putting
that in split screen, but I--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, you
actually shot a fake party?
AUDIENCE: Yeah
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think that it
would be a really good option
to try playing around
with that footage
and just using voiceover there.
AUDIENCE: I only put
it at half a screen,
because I'm keeping to
the left of the screen
so I have it on the right side.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
Is it super important
that you maintain
this footage of you talking?
Or can you just cut to
straight B-roll of the party?
AUDIENCE: I thought it
would be a nice transitions
to walk into the last scene.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, yeah.
I mean, I can tell that you
were very conscious of how
your cuts were being made.
MALE IN VIDEO: --the
grandfather paradox--
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think that
this opening one and some
of your pans are really slow.
So you could cut the clip
right before it lands on you
and just speed up the pan.
This part especially.
It just feels very nice.
MALE IN VIDEO: --sci-fi
films have depicted them.
We are, in fact, time traveling
at a pace of one hour per hour.
ELIZABETH CHOE: The script
is a lot better here.
It's really good.
MALE IN VIDEO:
--speeds near the--
ELIZABETH CHOE: And this too is
a really good visual reference
there.
AUDIENCE: I really
liked whatever
you did to animate the graph.
I was like, mind blown.
I don't know if I could do that.
But it looked really nice
because it followed your finger
and everything.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
how did you do that?
AUDIENCE: I kept a
screenshot there,
and I imported for the shot
that I drew everything over.
This amount of time
actually increases--
ELIZABETH CHOE: But YouTube
cut it off right at the bottom.
OK, that's what I
figured what happened.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it was
supposed to be nice frame.
I don't know why they
even warped this.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, I
mean, take the stabilizer out
and just do a
closeup shot of you.
Because that's really nice.
Are you going to do
it for this part too?
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking that I should.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
think you should,
just because like you're
throwing in the graph
and you have the asymptote,
and it's just such a key part.
Something that I didn't know
until you read the script out
loud to us-- really
cool, the idea
of looking at the other
side of the graph.
So, I know it's
more work for you,
but I think it would look cool.
Who's commenting on Kennith's?
AUDIENCE: Yuliya and Andrea.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yuliya
and Andrea, great.
AUDIENCE: I really
like the ending.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, the
beginning and ending, you book
ended it very nicely.
Very good.
I'm very happy with how people
have taken their scripts
and really created a point
and a story around it.
I don't think any
of these drafts
are instructional
videos whatsoever.
You've taken all
these concepts--
and we talked a lot
at the beginning
about tying specific
examples and allowing
a specific instance to let
you hit these bigger points.
And I think everyone's really
done a nice job of doing that
with their scripts.
All right, next
up we have Joshua.
You ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Any comments?
AUDIENCE: I haven't put
in the animations yet,
so there will be a part
where there's a blank space.
But the blank table is
supposed to be the animations.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi, have you found it
particularly difficult
to find a specific
item in your house?
Let's say you're looking
for a pair of gloves,
but you just can't find it and
you spend your entire afternoon
looking for it.
Well, you've just
encountered the same problem
that companies like
Google or Microsoft
encounter every single day.
And that's the
problem of search.
Just like a house, which stores
thousands of different items,
Google stores 45 billion
index pages of information.
When if every page
was a sheet of paper
and we stick them
up real high, we
will create a tower 600 times
taller than Mount Everest.
Well can Google find
my results so quickly
when I find so difficult
to find a pair of gloves?
Well, searching
on Google is kind
of looking for a
person in a big school.
Let's say you're looking for
James in the row of classrooms.
One of the easiest
method would be
to go to every classroom nearest
to you until you find James.
There's a better method
known as binary search.
Let's say the
students were arranged
from A to Z in an increasing
number of the classrooms.
And let's say we head to
the middle room first,
and if the person in the
middle room isn't James,
but his name starts
with a letter before j,
we head to the right.
If not, we head to the left.
We then approach the middle room
in the newly sectioned area.
We rinse and repeat.
Eventually we will find James
just like the first method,
but we find him in a much faster
way with the second method.
How much faster would that be?
Well, that depends on the number
of students in the school.
Let's say there are 500 students
and we're looking for one,
it would take about 80
minutes in the first manner,
but one and a half minutes
with binary search.
But let's say they are 1,000
students in the school,
it would take 160 minutes
with the first method
but 1.6 minutes with
the second method.
Now, that's a whole
lot of difference.
So a name is just a word.
But Google searches a
combination of words,
making it a little
bit more complicated.
So just like how we identify the
first letter of each alphabet
of the name, Google identifies
200 unique factors making
your search terms faster.
If you recall, the
effectiveness of binary search
depends on the
prearrangement of data.
And that's why computer
scientist are actively
looking for ways to sort,
manage, and eventually retrieve
data fast and better.
In the same way, the TV
remote goes near the TV,
the shoes go to the shoe rack,
the coats go into the cupboard
and the winter gloves go
into the winter jacket.
Aha!
So that's where my gloves are.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Joshua,
what are the things
that you like about your
cut, and what are the things
that you don't like about it?
AUDIENCE: I guess
I like the opening.
But I realize-- there
were times where
I realized I have a
better take, but it's
because they clicked it
but I started earlier.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
there were takes
where you got cut off
just at the beginning
or something like that.
AUDIENCE: So I realize
I should have much,
much more takes, because
you never know what happens.
And I had to scrap
out an entire scene
because I was in a location
where they had just
started preparing
for some event,
and then everything
became very noisy.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, so there
were like last minute things
that came up in your locations.
AUDIENCE: I do recognize
that the one where
I'm supposed to do
animations the sound is off,
and the visuals are
not really there yet.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You
mean the one where
you're looking at the desk?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, at the black--
[SKIPPING THROUGH VIDEO]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there's
supposed to be animations here,
but I guess this is not
probably the best one.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You were going
to have your animations come up
here with your hotel
room-- or your--
AUDIENCE: If I have
to redo a scene,
this scene is the most
inconsistent among the rest.
ELIZABETH CHOE: This was one
where you were filming later
in the day.
AUDIENCE: Yes, this
one was my first day,
but later in the evening.
And then the next day the rest.
Everything else in the
next day except this.
AUDIENCE: I think in
this piece, because A,
we don't have the
animation, but B,
your eyes are looking at
the animation as opposed
to still talking to
the screen-- and I
think, from my perspective, I
feel like there's a little bit
more of balance at play there
of connecting with the audience
a little with your eyes.
Like if you're going
to reshoot it, for me,
I think balancing looking
down and still looking back
instead of just looking
down during the animation
and then looking
back at the end.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Looking
at the animation is good.
It's kind of fun thing to do.
But again, look and acknowledge
the audience as well.
I think this one, it's
really just a matter
of energy level here.
Overall, your
delivery is very nice.
It's a very natural.
I love the script.
Again, you're taking something
that's very hard to visualize,
and that's why--
You know, we were
trying to figure out
what topic to do when
you were brainstorming,
and there were just no videos
on binary search, which
was shocking to me.
Or there aren't
very many good ones.
And there aren't very many
videos on how Google works,
period.
And it's because it's
very hard to visualize.
And I think you've
done a nice job.
The only thing is
this last scene.
The delivery is great.
But I almost would like to
see this done in a computer
lab or something instead of in
front of the Microsoft Office.
I know that you were trying to
work with sort of that Kendall
Tech area, but it reads
like a little maybe product
placement-y.
So if you want to reshoot
that one if you have time,
I would say there are
computer labs here that I can
help get you into if you want.
Were you going to have
animations in this scene?
AUDIENCE: This would be
just a number that pops up
and then a number below.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think
that sparing use of labels
will also help this video
too, like when you first
introduce the term binary
search, have come up.
When you talk about the numbers.
Numbers are hard to keep
track of in a video,
so just having those pop up.
AUDIENCE: So it would just
be first measure 80 minutes
and binary search 1.5.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
something like that.
Something really simple.
And you've got a good
background for it,
so I would go and
take advantage of it.
AUDIENCE: You have such
a smiley presence that's
so engaging on the camera.
You have such positive
energy up there.
It's like you kind of want to
smile while you're watching it.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And again, you're
taking something that is a
seemingly intimidating subject,
which again is why it's very
hard to find videos on computer
science, and even more rare
to find a live hosted video
on computer science.
All the ones that are
out there are usually
some sort of voiceover
animated tutorial,
and I think that having
you on screen being
the guide for the audience
with this is very, very nice.
It's very powerful.
AUDIENCE: Could you go back to
the beginning of that, where
you're in front of the
desk and about to point
at the animation?
MALE IN VIDEO: --find James.
There's a better method
known as binary--
AUDIENCE: I feel like
someone just told you a joke
and we missed the joke.
And you're like kind of
about to die laughing.
I don't know if you guys felt
that same way when you saw it.
Did someone tell you
something really funny?
AUDIENCE: I couldn't
figure it out.
I don't know why I
behaved like that.
I do remember a joke.
I did remember a joke.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to be
like, what was so funny?
There's something
funny going on here?
AUDIENCE: I must have saw
something that he was doing.
Maybe he was in an
awkward position.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I
think you're going
to refilm this one
anyway, but if you
do-- it was funny because in
this moment I was thinking,
there was something funny
that must have just happened,
and I don't know what it is.
ELIZABETH CHOE: What
was I going to say?
For the shots that you
did at the Koch Institute,
I think you can
just center this.
Center it close enough.
Because I know you're
trying rule of thirds here,
but there's sort of like-- it's
non-homogeneous distribution
of this pattern
in the background,
so it looks a little weird
to have all this extra space.
So I would go ahead
and just center this.
What do you guys think about
the music in this video?
It's good?
It's a little light-hearted.
It doesn't play into the
whole computer science
trope, which is nice.
I would bring-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was like
1950s suburbia, middle America
thing.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I would
bring down the levels
just a little bit.
In the opening it's fine,
but as it progressed,
I would either up your recorded
levels for your own audio
or lower the music.
Once the bass starts driving,
it gets a little distracting.
Any final comments?
Who's doing the Google
Docs for Joshua?
AUDIENCE: David and Nathan.
Also, just as a
comment, I think you
did a really,
really excellent job
with the pacing of your cuts.
We never explicitly
stated it, but I
think Elizabeth and I said it
in the computer lab last week.
You did a really good job
leaving a little bit of space
at the end of something that
you said for people to absorb.
But then when you
starting your new scene,
you cut it right
before you dialog.
And so the video itself just
felt really, really well-paced
because of that.
There was never any
point of it where
I was waiting for
something to happen.
It was all just like--
AUDIENCE: If I were
to add, they have
that actually I didn't
feel-- I cut once,
and I felt it was awkward.
And then I cut again, until it
reached so near to the audio.
So it was a few times I had to
cut to realize that it awkward.
Like even for 0.3 seconds,
it would be awkward.
AUDIENCE: You have really
good instincts to do that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And I know
that I have said this ad
nauseum in the emails,
but I feel like there's
this sense of fear.
And maybe it's just
the training that we
have in our traditional
educational system,
but we all want to
measure like 20 times
because heaven forbid we
cut more than once, right?
And here you're
literally cutting.
But it's through the process
of cutting and trying
different things that you
learn what feels right
and what makes
sense in the video.
And I don't know of
anyone who has ever made
a video on their first try.
Even if they've perfected the
shot list, gotten the best
script ever, have their
production date down
to the second, something
will ultimately
end up happening that
makes you reconsider
how you're going to cut things.
And it should.
It really should.
I mean, I am really
happy to hear that that's
what you discovered, because
I think that that goes maybe
a little against
how we traditionally
go through school.
So I'm glad to hear that
you try different things.
It's OK, do not be
discouraged by having
to try different cuts.
It's a productive process
that moves you forward.
OK, any thoughts from
PJ before we screen?
AUDIENCE: So there's parts
of the audio that I'm
moving so I can get the--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh,
you hear a little bit.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
after we do that.
And then it was
really hard trying
to keep it-- there's
no-- after watching it,
it's like two videos.
It's hard because
it's in one setting,
and they complete their form.
And I couldn't find like--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Music is hard.
It's so much harder than you
initially think it will be.
You think, oh you just like slap
something on in the background,
it'll be fine.
But it's very time consuming.
So it's very like--
I don't know.
It seemed very inspirational
at the beginning.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Like
inappropriately inspirational.
AUDIENCE: Friday Night
Lights kind of thing.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
Well, let's see.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When we take complex things and
break them into smaller pieces,
we find out that we know
a lot more about things
than we think.
Now let's take
this box-- ORCA I--
and create damage below
the water line, which
I've indicated right here.
As we can see, we've
damaged ORCA I right here.
Now let's put ORCA I on the
water and see what happens.
[GURGLING]
The ORCA I sank due to the
weight of the added water.
What if the ORCA I contained
cargo, or oil, or even people?
Now let's take ORCA II
and do the same thing.
So we can see that
ORCA II did not sink,
although it is sitting on
an angle towards the bow.
So why didn't ORCA II sink?
As easy as it sounds,
this simple demonstration
is essential to the design
of huge complex ships-- ships
that are responsible
for carrying about 90%
of all our stuff.
As naval architects,
how do we design
ships carrying our stuff to
make it into port safely and not
sink?
Well, why don't we find out?
Here we have ORCA I and
ORCA II from before.
Although ORCA I and ORCA II
don't engage in international
trade, they behave just as
a 1,000-foot container ship
would.
Now, let's take a
look in ORCA I. We can
see that there's nothing in it.
It's just a box.
But if we look at
ORCA II, we can
see that it's subdivided into
these watertight compartments
by these transverse
watertight bulkheads.
Now, what that
means is that if we
were to damage this
ship right here,
water would only flow
into this compartment.
It would not go into this
one, this one, or this one.
That would cause the ship to be
angled or trimmed in the water,
but it would not cause the
ship to sink completely.
We refer to ORCA II
as being subdivided,
and we can see subdivision in
many of these ship's plans.
It is unclear when
subdivision first
started being used in ships,
but accounts of 5th century
Chinese trade ships
indicate that water
would be able to enter the
vessel without sinking.
So let's find out
why this happens.
Let's imagine a barge divided
into 10 equal compartments.
One of them springs
a leak from damage.
Since the ship is subdivided,
only the first compartment
floods, and the
ship remains afloat,
protecting both its
people and cargo.
Although the added water
causes a ship to trim,
it still has enough buoyancy
to return to port for repairs.
Ships still sink, though.
It's both expensive
and impractical
to try to design
the unsinkable ship,
especially when these
ships will never
see that amount of damage.
That's why, as
naval architects, we
use computer programs to
help us out with subdivision.
Computers make it easy to
simulate certain damage
cases in practically no time.
With different software, we can
damage certain compartments,
and see how the
ship responds to it.
This gives the naval
architect a good idea
of what parts to improve
on the ship, if any.
So even though ships seem
like these intricate, complex
things, they're really
just based on principles
that we all already know.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Just
out of curiosity,
did you shoot this
video in sequence?
Like, you shot the first
scenes first, second--
AUDIENCE: So the first
scenes were second.
The second scenes were first.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Really?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That wasn't out
of design, it was
just because the the only time
we could go there was day.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, it's a
location practicality there.
Any comments for PJ?
AUDIENCE: I didn't feel
the change of music,
as in, it was natural.
I didn't feel like there
was a sudden change.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
liked the second song.
I agree that the first one is
a little Friday Night Lights.
[LAUGHTER]
ELIZABETH CHOE: The thing
with-- just like comedy,
pulling off drama is also really
hard to do in YouTube videos,
because you're not working
with, like, a sweeping epic
or a documentary.
It's like a little
YouTube blurb,
and we had trouble
with that with Farts
when he talks about how
Clostridium difficile kills
some thousand Americans a year.
We didn't want to have grandpa's
banjo playing in the background
when he says that, obviously.
But it's not like we were
going to insert music
from Gone with the Wind
in the background either.
AUDIENCE: Well, one thing
that I wanted to try music
because a lot of the places
I was in, there was-- you
can see there's a lot of
cuts, so where it goes to,
and if there's not
anything underneath,
it's very pronounced.
And I tried editing
a lot of it out.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Let's see.
So I know that you were
hesitant about being
in front of the camera too.
AUDIENCE: So natural.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And I'm surprised
that you said you filmed
them in the rivers,
because I feel like the stuff
that you have in the end
is really, really natural,
and I thought that you would
have maybe done that second.
It's hard to host while
you're doing a demo.
You just have a million
things to think about.
But in general, the
hosting is really nice.
It's really, really natural,
especially this part.
I can tell that Yuliya
and-- who was it--
David was filming with you?
AUDIENCE: Kenneth.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Kenneth
was filming with you.
They probably tried to make
you laugh in some of them
and smile.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they were
really good at doing that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I think this scene is
your strongest hosting.
Just, like, going back and
forth between the computer,
this scene just plays
out very nicely.
And again, taking a seemingly
intimidating subject,
and welcoming and
inviting the viewers in.
It's very nice.
I would say, in general,
the cutting advice
that [INAUDIBLE] gave,
which is to leave
the room at the end of cuts--
or at the end of scenes--
and cut very close
to when you start
talking at the beginning of
scenes, might help with this.
There was one--
AUDIENCE: Is it the moment where
Yuliya's in the picture with--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh, yeah.
That's, like, a
weird insert thing.
AUDIENCE: I was,
like, who is she?
What is she doing here?
She needs to get cut out.
ELIZABETH CHOE: In general,
I love the speed up walk,
and how you open the
door into the lab.
I love seeing the background.
It's very cool.
I think you can speed
up you damaging ORCA I.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And I think,
you say something like--
AUDIENCE: Let's take this box--
ORCA I-- and create damage
below the water line, which
I've indicated right here.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I think you can actually cut
that part out completely,
because after you cut it,
you say, as you can see,
we've damaged ORCA I, so I
think that's enough information.
And I get what you're
saying with the water line,
but I don't think it's
super relevant to the point
of the video, so I think it's
OK if you cut that out entirely.
Oh, yeah, when you
go from this scene--
AUDIENCE: --in the weight
of the added water.
What if the ORCA I contained
cargo, or oil, or even people?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
The music here is,
like, it's like trying
to pull out my heartstrings.
AUDIENCE: Now let's take ORCA
II and do the same thing.
We can see that ORCA II did
not sink-- ORCA II sink.
As easy as it sounds,
this simple demonstration
is essential to the design
of huge complex ships.
So why didn't ORCA II sink?
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
this is an example--
it happened one other time where
you leave a gap in between some
of your sentences, and
the gap is a little long.
So you can cut to a digital
zoom of the same shot
to clean up the
gap a little bit.
Because I think that you were
doing it to help you host,
and, like, help you get
through the lines, which
is totally OK and
understandable,
but I would just hide
that gap a little.
AUDIENCE: I stuttered here,
and I kept looking back
to the boat, so it
was weird, like I
was using that
almost as my crutch,
that I had this prop that I
could kind of like square up.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think
you actually were--
your delivery was fine here.
I wasn't distracted by it.
AUDIENCE: --II did not
sink, although it is sitting
an angle towards the bow.
So why didn't ORCA II sink?
ELIZABETH CHOE: I like the
way you ask the question.
That's, like, how
you would normally.
AUDIENCE: As easy as it sounds--
ELIZABETH CHOE: And see how
that gap feels just a little bit
too long.
AUDIENCE: --this simple
demonstration is essential
to the design of
huge complex ships--
ships that are responsible
for carrying about 90%--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Do you
have B-roll or pictures
of some of these ships?
That was the one
thing I was thinking
throughout this
video was, like, I
would love to see what the
things look like in real life.
AUDIENCE: I could probably
do something like that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think
this would be a great place
to cut to B-roll or pictures.
You can just keep the audio,
but that would help mix
up the visuals a lot too.
AUDIENCE: --of
all our stuff is--
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
So this cut was a
little-- this was
what I was talking about
with the line of sight
when I gave the editing lecture.
In the one scene, you're kind
of sitting like this, right?
And you have, like-- this
is a terrible drawing.
But you have your boat in the
water, and it's sort of, like,
a weird semi-bird's-eye.
And then you cut,
and you're not quite
in a different enough
position, so it feels
just, like, slightly jarring.
It feels like someone
just tipped the camera
over a little bit.
So either cut to a
closer shot of you
like that, to hide that a
little bit, or do B-roll there.
If you're coming
out of B-roll here,
then this transition
won't be as weird,
and my comment is totally
irrelevant, but just
something to think about.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
so-- sorry, I'm,
like, 10 steps ahead of my head,
where I am in actual reality.
You never put your
Coast Guard outfit on.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I felt like if I
wanted to try to make
it seem like less,
like, me talking,
that would have just put on
a whole different persona.
So I kind of, like,
I'm wearing boat shoes,
so that's hard to do.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I just wonder if at the
very, very last scene, where
you have your finale comment
about a very simple concept
as floating, if ever
there were a moment
to put that hat on, and have
your awesome Coast Guard
outfit on, that would be it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: If you
don't want to shoot it now,
we're going to make you
do it next week when
we shoot season 3, OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Got to go to the dry cleaners.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
that's a good comment.
AUDIENCE: The
thing that you have
that's so cool is, I mean,
we talked about the fact
that you actually,
legitimately, are out there
in the Coast Guard.
And you say that, but
showing us that in your film
is really powerful.
And even if, at
just the very end,
you tie that real
life application back,
I think that would be
really, incredibly cool.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Just for
the last sentence too.
And again, like, time
permitting, right?
Because I know that you guys
don't have a ton of time
to incorporate all this stuff.
You've already gotten
plenty of footage
of you talking in
this setting, so it
wouldn't be very
jarring to have you
say the last sentence, like,
out by the sea, or by the boats.
AUDIENCE: Or even if
when you say, like,
I'm a Coast Guard, whatever,
even if you quickly
have a picture of even photos of
you in uniform, to just put-- I
don't know.
I don't know how
that would look.
But just something that
shows us, and doesn't tell us
this totally authentic side
to yourself would be cool.
AUDIENCE: So do you have
access to the base here?
AUDIENCE: To the
one in North End?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because one of our--
AUDIENCE: They
have shirts there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, one of the Sloan
fellows is also an officer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: No.
He's based in there.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
again, I know it's
short notice-- you'd have to do
it between today and tomorrow,
basically, so it's OK
if you can't do it,
but something to think
about, if you want
to do it for Science Out Loud.
All right.
Yuliya, you ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So there are-- the beginning
and the end, we filmed outside.
There's a lot of wind, and
I couldn't connect the mike,
because I was standing far away.
So I tried to do voiceover.
I don't know how it
sounds, because honestly, I
was just tired of hearing
my voice at that point.
And then, there is this,
actually, like the thumbnail,
this is where the animation
is supposed to be.
So the white screen
is animations.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: David and
Kenneth are the ones
who are Google Doc
commenting on this.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Thank you.
And we'll go through it
again if you guys forget.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hi.
What do snowflakes and
cellphones have in common?
Well, let me start by
drawing a snowflake first.
I draw an equilateral
triangle, divide each side
into three parts, and draw
another equilateral triangle
on top of each one.
Then take out the
middle, and repeat
the process, this time
with 1, 2, 3, 4 times
3, which is 12 sides.
Eventually, the shape will start
looking something like this.
In mathematics, this is
called a Koch snowflake.
If I repeated my
process again and again,
I would see this same
pattern anywhere I looked.
This is a Koch snowflake,
this time drawn on a computer.
Such neverending patterns,
that on any scale,
on any level of zoom,
look roughly the same,
are called fractals.
Computer scientists can
program these patterns
by repeating an often
simple mathematical process
over and over.
In the 1990s, a radio astronomer
by the name of Nathan Cohen
used fractals to revolutionize
wireless communications.
At the time, Cohen was having
troubles with his landlord.
The man wouldn't let him
put an antenna on his roof.
So Cohen designed a more compact
fractal radio antenna instead.
The landlord didn't notice
it, and it worked better
than the ones before.
Working further, Cohen
designed a new antenna,
this time using a fractal
called the Menger sponge.
The Menger sponge is
not really the sponge
you'd be scrubbing
your back with,
but you can still
think of it like that.
Imagine both water and soap
getting through your sponge's
holes, except the water
is Wi-Fi, and the soap is,
say, Bluetooth.
The fractal's
infinite sponginess
allows it to receive many
different frequencies
simultaneously.
Before Cohen's
invention, antennas
had to be cut for one frequency,
and that was the only frequency
they could operate at.
Without Cohen's
sponge, your cell phone
would have to look
something like a [INAUDIBLE]
to receive multiple
signals, including
the one your friends
use when they call.
Cohen later proved that
only fractal shapes
could work with such a
wide range of frequencies.
Today, millions of
wireless devices,
such as laptops and
bar code scanners,
use Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
Nature has been doing
it the whole time,
and not just the snowflakes.
Natural selection favors
the most efficient systems
and organisms, often
of a fractal form.
The spiral fractal,
for example, is
present in seashells,
broccoli, and hurricanes.
The fractal tree is
relatively easy to program,
and can be used to study
river systems, blood
vessels, and lightning bolts.
So many natural systems
previously thought off limits
to mathematicians can now be
explained in terms of fractals.
Mathematics allows us to
learn nature's best practices
and then apply them to
solve real world problems.
Much like Cohen's antenna
revolutionized the field
of telecommunications,
other fractal research
is changing medicine,
weather prediction,
and building design here at MIT
and everywhere in the world.
Look around you.
What beautiful
patterns do you see?
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
Any thoughts from anyone?
Should we dive right in?
Yuliya, what are your favorite
and least favorite parts
about this cut?
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
There was some scenes that
I liked better than others.
That's mostly because of
the lighting and the sound.
I think the one in
the classroom had
a nice sound and nice lighting.
So I guess the indoor scenes
were a lot easier to shoot.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So I
think, in general, again,
very nice script.
This came such a long way from
the initial ideation phase,
and I think it is, like
computer science-- I mean,
my favorite thing about all the
videos that you guys have done
is the topics are so unique,
and so different than what
people normally get in school.
And they're taking
all these concepts
that they've learned in
school, but just putting it
in a very different context.
And it's hopefully because
you're talking about the things
that you're excited about.
And so I'm really happy with
how you've transformed, like,
math, which is, again,
a very hard video
to do if you don't do it
in the style of Vi Hart,
and putting your
face and hosting it.
It's done nicely.
I think, in general, the video
has a very fast pace to it,
and I don't know if it's
because the cuts are happening
so frequently, or you're
naturally a very animated
person, which is nice, but
leave a little bit of room,
like, a little bit of breathing
space to compensate for that.
I think maybe the reason
why it was hard for me
to follow a little
bit was the opening
seemed a little too short.
And I know that you had edited
it from the last time I had
seen it, but let's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hi.
What do snowflakes and
cell phones have in common?
Well, let me start by
drawing a snowflake first.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
It seems like it's
so overly condensed.
And I know you had brought
it down from something that
was a little bit
bigger, but I think
that it's just so, like, it
comes out of nowhere, like, hi.
What do these have in common?
It's like, wait, what?
Like, I wouldn't have
had that question.
And even getting rid of
the hi helps with that.
It's a nice question.
What do snowflakes and cell
phone antennas have in common?
But there's not enough
of a lead into you
going into describing
what a fractal is, yet
fractals is on the title.
I think that maybe you
could do a little bit
with the transition
there, and I'll
brainstorm with you, because
I can't think of anything
off the top my head.
Do you guys have any
suggestions for that opening?
Yeah, Andrea.
AUDIENCE: Maybe like, I
don't know exactly how
you could do it, but almost like
the first shot, where you're
saying, what do snowflakes--
and then you see, like,
sort of an image of a
snowflake and cell phones,
and then it sort of
zooms out, and you
realize that the picture
is on the cell phone.
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
have in common.
And then, you're-- and then you.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
mean, I think it's
OK to introduce the
idea of fractals,
as long as you set it
up a little bit more.
So something like, what do
snowflakes and cell phones
have in common?
Neverending repeating
patterns called fractals.
And then do a little bit
of a slower transition
into you at the blackboard here.
Something a little
bit more like that.
I think the visuals help a lot.
I know that you had filmed up
in Stata, because eventually you
talk about how it
affects architecture,
but I don't think that
this location is super
vital to the
opening, and I think
you can get cleaner
audio if you do VO,
or if you just re-shoot
it with you on the table,
and then you have a picture
of a snowflake that comes up
in a picture of a cell phone,
or something like Andrea said.
But I think having the audience
onboard from the get-go
will help with the pacing of
the video as it continues.
I know that you had
struggled with the music too,
and I think-- I don't
know-- so much of music
is personal taste.
To me, all I can
think about when
I hear this music is, like,
old Korean soap operas.
And so I don't know
if it is, like,
the most appropriate
tone, and maybe I
feel that way because of
experiences of my parents
watching them, but I think
you could play around
with some other pieces.
I like the general
tempo of the music,
and how it's sort of
this same melody on loop
in the background, so it's
not super distracting,
and it's a good volume.
But I would play around
with a couple other songs,
and I can help you
with that, if you
want to run some options by me.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
use this one because it
was kind of calming, so kind of
to offset the general fast pace
and animated
talking to something
soothing in the background.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah So I think
it's a good tone to start with,
and again, maybe it's just
my personal preference,
but something about it
made me fixate on the music
more than on the text.
Did anyone else
have-- maybe it really
is, just, like I can't get
over how much it reminds
me of Korean soap operas.
AUDIENCE: It stood out
for me at the start,
like, especially
for this scene, it
gave me the feeling like it was
going to something romantic.
I don't know.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's
very sentimental,
like the music evokes
something very sentimental,
just like the opening
of the ships one
evokes a mood that's
very different from what
you're about to go into.
And especially if you open
with something like that,
if you'd open with a banjo
thing-- or not the banjo--
whatever you had for
the second piece,
I think it would have been fine.
But something about
opening with music
that sets a tone that's very
different from what you're
intending to achieve, it
threw me off a little bit.
But luckily, it's something
that it's easily fixable.
You can easily play around
with different types of music.
AUDIENCE: Because
for me, you give us,
because there was
a Digicom video,
and there was the idea that you
could use something calming,
so I tried to use
something calming,
but as you see, I
didn't choose that,
because I realized the
calming one will make
my video feel very monotonous.
But when I observe the
Digicom audio closer,
I realized there was
some percussion notes,
so that helped.
So maybe you could
find something
similar to what you have right
now, but with a little bit--
not too much-- percussion here
would help with the pacing.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
That's really good.
And again, with music, there's
no hard and fast rules with
what works and what doesn't.
I mean, a lot of
it is just, like,
your gut feeling when you
hear it, if it makes sense,
or if it doesn't.
And obviously, my gut feeling
was very different from
everyone else's.
Yeah, Jamie?
AUDIENCE: First of all, compared
to where we started, this is
isn't, like, oh my goodness.
This is way, way more
awesome than I ever thought
was possible, with
our first conversation
about it's not real,
so this is like--
and what I loved with the
fractal piece at the beginning,
where you really explained,
because we gave you
that feedback in
the last time, was
you need to set us up for
success in explaining what
a fractal actually
is, and I thought
you did a really fantastic job.
One think that you
may want to think
about is you have a
very sing-songy voice.
Your voice is high, and
it's kind of sing-songy.
And at the beginning,
you set up this--
I don't know if you've
ever seen Mrs. Doubtfire,
but it's this movie where
Robin Williams is dressed up
as this old
grandmother, and is just
kind of this hilarious figure.
And I think there's
an unintended humor
to your sing-songy-ness
at the very beginning that
makes me feel less credible
wanting to watch you.
And I think there's a
very simple fix, which
is just grounding your
voice in a lower register.
When you talk with
your voice later on,
just listen to that
as you watch yourself.
I notice that the times when
your voice is a little lower
is when I don't notice that
as much, and so since you are
thinking of reworking
this first scene,
you may want to think
about consciously grounding
your voice a little
bit more in your chest,
so that we don't,
like, unintentionally
think it's funny when
it's not intended to be.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And I know George
had said the camera
calms you down,
and in general it does, and you
compensate with higher energy,
but again, this is what I
saying before, and oftentimes,
hopefully, this stuff that
we were saying earlier
in the class makes a little more
sense after you guys have gone
through it, but sometimes
the tendency is to compensate
or equate higher energy
to higher pitch, higher
volume, like, higher
everything, and it's really not
that at all.
A lot of it is just
the mentality of,
like, I'm going to be really
present here, right now,
and really give it 100% here.
AUDIENCE: There's
actually a really good TED
Talk that's about how to
speak to be listened to.
And it's basically, you do
these little vocal exorcises,
and they both relax
you, and they'll
drop your register down,
like, just going through them.
And I had to do those
prior to doing--
I learned something
similar when I was first
learning public speaking.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
It's a great thing
to think about not just
with making these videos,
but when you're
giving talks later on.
Again, like, when you're
nervous or excited,
your tendency is to talk a
lot with your hands, which
I know I do, and talk
really high pitched.
So it's just a good thing
to think about, in general,
after this class.
AUDIENCE: Number two.
AUDIENCE: At the beginning
of those voiceovers,
I was trying to match
the video in my room.
And it did feel a
little bit off as well.
I wasn't sure how to--
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think
you could do the opening,
like, just you set up
a tripod, and sitting
in your room or something,
just something really simple.
What do this and
this have in common?
Well, it's actually
neverending repeating
patterns called fractals, and
then you go into fractals.
AUDIENCE: On a very
practical level,
like, I do a lot of helping
of people get ready for talks
in my lab, and just, like,
grounding your feet wherever
you are, feeling like you're
grounded to the earth,
and then getting a really deep
breath, like way from in here
before you speak, that will
help you fight that tendency
to go way up high.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And I
think the animations here
will look really good.
Again, like, visual
cues, anything
that you're going to add, even
if it's just still pictures
will make a big difference.
And I would play around
with the ending too.
I like that you do the review,
but again, the audio is hard
when you're that far away.
And you may be able to
shoot this in the same room
that you shoot the opening
in-- or you re-shoot it,
and then, I don't know,
have a picture of Stata
just pop up next to you.
I think that's a way to
compensate pretty easily.
What is the world
background for?
AUDIENCE: It matches the
world at the very end.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And it was just a nice
background for titles.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh.
I would just go black, honestly.
Just a black background.
In general, I think simple
reads more professional.
Oh, I don't know.
Professional's not the right
word, but simple is better,
I think.
And I didn't make the
connection of, like, look
at the world when I
saw the background.
It's such a minor thing, though.
I mean, it's just your
credit, so it's OK,
but just something
to think about.
Any final comments for Yuliya?
AUDIENCE: I thought that
one scene in the dorm
was really good, where
you inadvertently
had all the stuff behind us.
I didn't know that it was
going to turn out like that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, the
one in the lounge.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I think it was the best
lighting, too, of all of them.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
So who's going to
comment on Yuliya's?
AUDIENCE: PJ and Josh.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
Last one, and then
we'll take a break.
David, do you want to say
anything before we screen?
Your video will just
speak for itself.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-If I went out for a run
now, dressed like this,
you'd probably call
me nuts, right?
Because it's so
cold outside that
I'd probably die of hypothermia.
However, in 2009,
Wim Hof managed
to run a full marathon in
minus 20 degrees Celsius,
wearing nothing but shorts.
While most people would probably
die, Wim Hof has survived.
So what makes Wim Hof able to
survive where others can't?
The research team
were suggesting
that they subjected him to an
icy bath for almost two hours.
While most people would have
their core body temperature
drop to below 35 degrees,
causing hypothermia to kick in,
Wim Hof's body
temperature dropped
to a merely 37.4
degrees Celsius,
staying surprisingly warm.
And the funny thing is that
the researchers couldn't
find exactly what had happened.
Maybe it's his genetic
ancestry that saves him.
In a sample study,
studies have found
that individuals with
cold-climate ancestry,
have been found to
have mitochodria
that can produce more heat
and less chemical energy.
Mitochondria is
like a mini-furnace
that burns the sugars
from the food you eat
into chemical and heat energy.
Individuals like this are
better able to survive the cold,
however, scientists haven't
fully studied Wim Hof's genome,
so we don't really know.
Wim Hof practices
g-tummo, a Tibetan form
of meditation and
breathing, which allows
him to double his metabolism.
Remember those mitochondria
I mentioned before?
Wim Hop can produce enough
heat through these mitochondria
with special breathing, and
massive contractions that
can produce enough
heat to body warm.
Well, you might be tempted
to believe that this
is wishy-washy nonsense.
However, participants
in a study at NUS
have been shown to
increase their core body
temperature using g-tummo, and
they had no prior experience.
Now, why is it so?
Strong increases in
brain waves were noticed,
and many have theorized
that this enables the body
to effectively heat the center
as well as distribute it
to the extremities.
We do not fully understand
Wim Hof's methods.
Although some have tried
to follow in his footsteps,
you would be unwise
to do the same.
And Wim Hof even claims
that he can control
other parts of his body.
Now, if this is true, and
scientifically a fact,
who knows what doors could open.
And since science hasn't
figured it out yet,
and I, myself, don't
practice these methods,
maybe I'd better be off
donning more jackets.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: David,
what was the hardest
part about filming this video?
AUDIENCE: I think it was
following the script.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Following the script.
Just, like, remembering
it when you were shooting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I really think that
was the hardest,
because trying to say everything
while looking at a camera
felt very, very real.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yep.
That makes a lot of sense.
And again, like, using
your partner to the fullest
extent when you're
filming can really
help with that
sort of humanizing
the mechanical
element of production,
trying to talk to the
person behind the camera.
I think that you didn't look
uncomfortable on camera.
The only thing is, in
general, you talk really fast,
and with the music
that was in it,
I think that you can
take some of the music
out, or drop the volume a
ton, or play with, like,
less busy music.
But having someone who talks
naturally fast, and then, like,
very upbeat music
in the background
is just, like,
exacerbate, it's, like,
constructive interference.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
calm music,
but I felt like I
put calm music in.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I mean, you can also
experiment with not using music
in certain parts of the video.
You guys don't need to have
music the whole way through.
It's OK.
And I think because you
talk so fast naturally,
the music can be-- remember,
with music, first do no harm,
right?
It can be hard to understand
just the sheer amount
of content that you're
saying when the music is
so upbeat and so loud.
AUDIENCE: I think the music was,
at least for me, personally,
it had the same effect as
when Elizabeth was showing
the choices for the heart
video, where at the beginning,
it was a little bit too much
for me, and I got the giggles.
I don't know what about you
putting on running shoes,
and, like, just the
loudness of that music,
it just seemed a
little bit ridiculous,
that I wasn't mentally
ready for some serious facts
at that point.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to make it upbeat.
I wanted it to be like I was
going to run in the cold.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
AUDIENCE: It's good,
like, until the point
where you ask the question.
From, like, instead of being,
like, oh, OK, it's OK to be,
like, oh, this is me when
I'm running in the cold.
But then as soon as you
switch to actual explanation--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I would just duck it out
after you ask the question.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-If I went out for a run
now dressed like this,
you'd probably call
me nuts, right?
Because it's so
cold outside that
I'd probably die of hypothermia.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And also there, I
mean, everyone's done
this, where they take
pauses in weird parts of
their sentences-- I mean,
if you wanted to make it
funny, I don't know if you do.
AUDIENCE: She's making--
ELIZABETH CHOE: I am so sorry.
AUDIENCE: I think it's one
of my favorite things--
ELIZABETH CHOE: The last time
this happened, I was thinking,
oh my gosh, this
happens to be more
than I would like to
admit, but I was, like,
I hope this doesn't
happen during the class,
and it ends up on the internet,
but now it's going to anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
If you wanted to
make it funny, you
could zoom in-- as
you-- nevermind.
Don't make it funny.
AUDIENCE: So if
you wanted-- I was
going to say-- every time you
pause, cut out that pause,
and then maybe a little bit
closer to your face, like,
what if I die?
And then, like,
zoom in, I'm cold.
That's really comedic.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's kind of
like the thing that we did,
and it's not very good,
like the extreme zoom,
and you could make it,
like-- with comedy,
going big or going home works
the best, because you really
have to commit to it, so
if you want it to have
a huge comedic effect,
you would, like,
zoom in really close,
and you would have, like,
a weird sound effect.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
really funny to you.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But if you
don't want to make it funny,
which I would recommend, either
cut out the gaps and alternate
between zooming in and out like
Hank Green does on SciShow.
There's one other time that
happens, like, right here.
In general, like, if
your gaps are happening
in places that are not
at the ends of scenes,
really be conscious of
how long those last.
And having two other people
look at your video today
will help, because
sometimes it's
hard to tell when
you're watching yourself
if something looks like it's
lasting too long or not.
But if you have gaps
that are too long that
are in the middle
of your scenes,
you can use the trick
of digital zooming
in and out to hide the cuts.
Does anyone have
general comments?
Yes, Yuliya.
AUDIENCE: I like the delivery.
It was really natural.
And the music was
sometimes distracting.
Another thing that
had that effect
were some of the backgrounds,
so like the one where you're
holding a trashcan,
and there's a person,
and then there's a trashcan.
So I wasn't sure,
like, did that mean
the person was in the
trashcan, like, what happened,
and, like, yeah,
like, this scene.
And then there were some
others, like the lab.
I wasn't sure why
the lab was there.
Even though it was really cool.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
know that you held up
the trashcan because
you were trying to say,
like, he was in a bucket.
But again, with the music,
it's hard to hear that you're
explaining the bucket
thing, so I would just
cut to the picture of him
before you hold up the trashcan.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --team were suggesting that
they subjected him to an icy
bath for almost two hours.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
I mean, in general,
that line is spoken
so quickly that it's hard
to follow what you're doing.
AUDIENCE: And it's
not just the speed.
I think you need to put
a little more diction
in between your words, so that,
like, what I hear happening
in they're kind of
slurring all together,
so it's not just
a matter of speed,
but it's that I'm having
trouble actually separating
this word from this word,
and therefore, there
are chunks that feel
like one big long word,
that they're actually made
up of four or five words.
I think there's a piece of
slowing down, but then also,
forcing yourself to use
over-diction to clarify
your words.
That'll help a lot
too, more so than you
think, because it will help
clean up those little spaces
in between the words to then
provide me with a little more,
like, OK, I'm with you every
single step of the way, if that
makes sense.
So if you are going to do
any retaking of videos,
try really hard to
really tighten up the way
that you say the
words, in addition
to slowing down a little bit.
I think that'll help people.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I think if you
do that, that'll inherently
help you slow down, because
you're going to think
about each word at a time.
I like the use of pictures here.
It's really helpful,
because this
is an instance where we
just don't have access
to shoot any of this.
I would play around with, in
general, zooming in and out,
when you're doing long takes.
I forgot to mention
this, but I thought
that was a really nice thing
that Yuliya did in her video,
was-- because we had talked
about this last week--
how to clean up
some of the gaps--
and she does some nice
work with cutting into,
just like her hand
drawing the fractals,
and I think that,
in general, people
can take more advantage
of that technique.
Oh.
So here you're cutting
in between closeups,
but this is another thing
with the iTrace, where
in the first scene you're on the
left, and on the second scene,
you're on the right,
and you're also not
in the same 3D plane of
field as you were before.
So in the previous scene,
you were close to the bench,
and here, did you
scoot up forward?
So it's not terrible-- it's
not like the end of the world
or anything, but it's,
like, a little jarring,
and I guess I'm
subconsciously taking time
to adjust my sense
of space and where
you are when that cut happens.
I don't necessarily think
you have to re-shoot it,
but I would either--
let's watch it.
AUDIENCE: And they had
no prior experience.
Now, why is it so?
Strong increases in
brain waves were noticed,
and many have theorized
that this enables the body
to effectively heat the center
as well as distribute it
to the extremities.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Is there a B-roll
that you could use there?
Because I think that's a really
good opportunity to-- it's
a key point that
you're connecting
what someone is doing
with their mind,
and how that's
legitimately connecting
to the rest of their body.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH CHOE: Could you even
just use pictures of the brain,
and then, like, the human body?
Again, this is a really
hard thing to visualize,
and I know you're not working
with a ton of resources,
but I think that's
an opportunity
to maybe try voiceover
with the technique
that Jamie was talking about,
because it's such a crucial bit
to the video, actually.
That's where you're
actually tying the science
into something that seems
a little pseudo science.
AUDIENCE: Keeping that in
mind, as you watch your video--
and whoever's talking
over with you,
really connecting
it and grounding it
in the real science too.
Because I liked your
furnace metaphor,
but then I was distracted by
the burning exploding boxes,
and if I've never heard
of mitochondria before,
or cellular respiration
type things,
that wouldn't be very distanced.
I would think explosions
rather than this is grounded
in my biology type things.
And so maybe think
of places, where
you can include images like
the circulatory system, things
like that.
Just, like, keep grounding it.
AUDIENCE: When you cut from
the guy doing meditation
to you sitting cross-legged,
was that purposeful?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'm supposed to be
doing meditation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's what I thought.
Because I was like, not 100%
sure, but I was pretty sure
that was a choice that you made.
There's no comment.
I just had a question.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Any
other thoughts for David?
So you guys want to do Google
Docs versus just talking one
on one with people?
Is that the consensus?
AUDIENCE: Could we do both?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah.
You can totally do both.
So the rest of class time is
for feedback for each other,
and this is a super, super
crucial, critical part
of the production process.
During the break,
I will post a link
onto the Tumblr that has all
the Google Docs that I will
finish making for everyone.
So for example, Yuliya, your two
commenters are Joshua and PJ.
So Josh and PJ, just go into
your corresponding page,
and on the time code,
just leave your comments.
I will comment on everyone's
rough cuts as well.
And again, don't worry if you're
repeating the same remarks
as other people are doing.
How about we spend-- after the
break-- doing the Google Docs
stuff, and then whenever
you guys finish,
I guess, in the order
of people finishing,
group up, and give one
on one feedback as well.
And we can help
facilitate that too.
Does that sound
good to everyone?
The hardest part is over.
The hardest part is just
getting the first cut.
It's getting the first
script out there.
And hopefully, moving
forward, going to Thursday,
it'll be easier.